why do you teach your students three
different types of story structures so
you have the hero's journey the three
act structure and then something that
was new to me which is the jules selbos
11 step model
yeah so
you know there are all these different
story structure models out there in the
world and you know they just have
different terms but they're all
basically kind of the same approach to
story structure
um
so and every writer has a different
process and a way of thinking about
stories so i think it's really good to
expose yourself as a writer to all the
different models and see okay which one
helps me you know and i think the
important thing to remember is it's
their forms not formulas it's not
something you should follow like paint
by number like here's page 30 this is
where the turning point mid six midpoint
is on page 60 you know like
like i really use these um story models
as inspiration rather than you know some
sort of set of rules that i have to
follow um and so i like to give my
writers different tools to put in their
toolbox and then to use the ones that
are helpful to them and there are um
there are three that i really like and
there's others too that are really
amazing but i just find
it you know i don't want to give people
too many things which just makes them
crazy and confused including myself by
the way so um i like the hero's journey
which we've already talked about um and
i use that which is you know the
ordinary world the call to adventure the
refusal to the call out of fear
meeting the mentors crossing the
threshold blah blah
so so for those those people that are
really interested in psychological
storytelling and emotional journeys i
think that's
that's the number one one and you know
that story model is fascinating because
joseph campbell who actually identified
that pattern of storytelling you know he
studied myths and fairy tales across all
different kinds of cultures and across
all recorded history
and it's the same pattern
so
it it and he sort of likens characters
in these myths and fairy tales to those
that carl jung found in our unconscious
brain
and it's like i think the reason this
story model is so powerful
is it comes from our human brain
our need to have a story told in a
certain way where we're processing our
own fears and our own
struggles you know um
so i i love that story model um it helps
me a lot again not a formula it's a form
you can move those and shift those
phases around
you know or dr or not have a phase you
know it's up to you to use it creatively
and you can see that pattern in
hollywood movies you can also see it in
more independent character driven
slightly experimental films you can find
traces of it so it just depends how much
you want to embrace that in your in your
structure
um and then i also talk a little bit
about three-act structure which is kind
of the way everybody talks about story
structure you know um ordinary world
inciting incident
act one turning point you know um
midpoint end of act two where the
everything falls apart and then i'm
gonna try one more time and then climax
and then resolution
and that's just a really simple way to
think of feature writing which is mostly
what i focus on with writers um
so there's that model um and then
there's the jewel selbo model and i'm
gonna get my cheat sheet oh please do
yeah yeah this was new to me but i jules
selbo wrote a book i can't remember the
name of it but it's um it's
j-u-l-e-s-e-l bow
s-e-l-b-o and she is wonderful and this
this way of telling feature um stories
is so simple and so clear and i just
find it really helpful so i'll share
that with you um
and again you know if if you find that
this is like working for you and you
really um
are attracted to it like get her book
because it explains it in much more
detail
um but she basically says there are 11
steps in a feature film the first step
is the character's overall want and why
so you establish through action what
they want and why they want it and then
the character logically goes for it so
they take action to try to get that
thing that they want
but the character is somehow denied
okay they they that's not gonna work
they can't they can't get it that way
um but the character gets a second
opportunity
to um achieve their overall want
but
there's danger around that second
opportunity like it's kind of a shady
way maybe it's not on the up and up but
there's some danger around it either
emotionally or physically okay
but they want it so badly at the end of
act one
they go for it
they decide to go for it again
these these forms are the same like
they're just different language around
the same turning points and stuff but at
the end of act one the character decides
to go for it and now we're in act two
right and so um
all goes well they're going for it look
they're getting what they want oh my god
but
something happens in the middle of the
script and one thing i would love to
share with your viewers is this idea of
the midpoint you know sometimes the
midpoint people think of it as like
something happens out of the blue that
that
causes everything to fall apart or it's
like a false victory and then they have
to deal with its false or whatever but i
always think the best midpoints are a
moment where the character just like
everything's going okay they're getting
what they want but then they get to that
cave and it's like they're in that cave
and their fear is around them and they
make a decision out of fear
that causes everything to fall apart for
them they go back to their old pattern
and that actively gives them
like they drive that midpoint and and
causes everything to fall apart which in
joules um
11 step structures called all falls
apart
right so all falls apart looks like
they're going to fail
and then at the end of act two there's a
crisis where they again have to make a
decision or a commitment
do they go for a new strategy do they
give up
you know what do they do usually they
decide to try again
and that decision or that crisis
decision drives them into act three
um and then we have this climax where
it's the final attempt to get what they
want and again usually we have a
transformation right they do something
they never could have done back in act
one they get what they want and then the
last phase she calls truth the truth
comes out to make things right and this
is where um
that the character discovers something
new about her world she has some new
insight about herself
and that usually has the power to heal
whatever was broken back at the
beginning of the story
um and so what i love about this this
story model is that it's really goal
driven
you know it's like they want something
they decide to go for it they get
blocked they get a second opportunity
i'm afraid i want it so much i'm going
to go for it it's just it allows you to
really find that goal for your character
and let them pursue that in the story
that's awesome and who was jewel salvo
jules selbo is an incredible writer i
can't say enough great things about her
she's a friend she's
a wonderful woman she's super talented
writer
i met her as just a colleague as a
writer and a person who worked with
screenwriting students
she's written a bunch of different
movies she did a lot of animation she's
writing novels now
she just wrote a new kind of like
detective novel that just came out
um and she's phenomenal and i think
she's still teaching
but she really just looked at all this
material out there and she said i'm
going to make up my own
version of this that's really simple
it's really character and goal driven
and i've used that 11 step story
structure a lot in my own work and with
clients
now you have a film that you wrote and
directed that starred alicia silverstone
yes and it's a true crime it's called
true crime okay yes please don't watch
it it's not very good oh no no no i
would love to tell my true crime story
if people are interested if any if any
of your viewers are interested in being
filmmakers um in addition to being
writers you know like wanting to make
your own films um because i actually
started out and i wanted to be a
director and i went to ucla film school
i was in the directing program there i
got my mfa there
and i was um positive that that's what i
wanted to do
until i directed a movie called true
and i just found um
it was it was a great experience like i
learned so much but i also realized i'm
not a director like i don't enjoy being
kind of the focus of everybody's
questions and lots of
stress and all that stuff i really
realized like oh my gosh i had such a
great time writing the script like i'm
the right i'm the writer i'm not the
director
but it was it was a great experience and
what it taught me as a writer
is because because i was directing it
too and it was pretty low budget you
know at the time we had like 18 days to
shoot it so it was kind of crazy um
what i've what i found is and i wish i
had known this before i actually
directed it
is how important it is if you're
actually making your own scripts like
you're and you're kind of doing it diy i
mean i had a studio that i think the
budget was 1.2 million dollars which at
the time was it was a decent low-budget
movie um but what i wish i had known and
i wish i had listened to people who told
me is you know
make it contained
don't have a lot of different locations
really boil your script down to only the
scenes that you absolutely need to tell
your story because what ended up
happening is that we would have company
moves and
i just i every day i lost scenes where
the producers were just like we can't
shoot that scene because we're not
enough time
and so it was just very frustrating to
to watch my story you know eventually it
kind of makes sense you know in the
editing room we had to kind of rewrite
the movie to to fix all the things that
we couldn't shoot um but and it kind of
worked out but um what was great about
it is i learned i didn't want to be a
director i really learned that i am a
writer through and through i like being
alone yes i like being with other people
in a room too but i do not like being on
a set and being in charge of a bunch of
people
it was just extremely uncomfortable for
me
sure i mean sometimes the idea of
something sounds wonderful and the title
of it and then once you actually get
into doing it then you realize that okay
this isn't for me but is it for me i'm
gonna get through this you know and i
had done it in film school i had
directed several films which i loved
doing but it was on a much smaller scale
it was just
my friends and i making a movie and it
was great but when it became this big
thing i just realized
you know i don't have the temperament to
really um deal with all the stress
sure sure now um what prompted you to
write the story
the um that story oh that was that this
is actually might be really interesting
um for your viewers um i got out of film
school and i you know i said i was in
the directing program so i had a couple
short films that i had made but my agent
said you need to write something you
need to write a feature and i was like
okay um what should i write about i have
no idea and i remembered back to
something that happened to me when i was
a little girl
um when i was like 9 or 10 years old i
was at my grandparents house and i was i
don't know i was looking for something
and i went to my grandfather's closet
and i found the stack of true detective
magazines which back in the day were
like
you know the way we have true crime now
it's all over television well back in
the day it was kind of this secret thing
and there were these magazines right
and um i was like oh what are these
magazines you know i'm like a 10 year
old oh and i open them up and it's like
literally photos of like dead bodies
with like black strips over their eyes
and i was just like
ah what is this and then i was reading
and that they described like how the
person got murdered and how the
detectives you know went after them and
figured out who had committed the crime
and everything and part of me was like
this whole ugly world of like the real
world was opened up to me but i also was
like
this is cool like detective stuff like i
like this you know but my grandfather
was like patty and i was like oh put it
away pretend like i never thought
what i'm innocent um
but i also you know it really ignited in
me this interest in true crime which i
still have
um but as i was thinking of you know
what i want to write i was like oh maybe
i could write about like that thing of
finding those magazines so i ended up
fictionalizing it and i just made it
about a high school girl who's obsessed
with true crime magazines
and um a girl at her high school gets
murdered and she decides she's gonna
find out who the killer was so it's kind
of like a nancy drew
kind of
you know beast b-level movie about this
girl who wants to find the killer
and it's kind of a coming-of-age story
really um but it came from my own
experience you know and and a lot of the
stuff that i write
it it may not be technically literally
what happened to me but there's always
something in there that did happen to me
you know and so i think when you're
looking for a story you always want to
have that personal connection somehow
because that's kind of where the juice
is for you as a writer
you know especially if you're scared to
write it that's a good thing
well the million dollar question is what
was the theme
[Music]
i think the theme
ended up being
be careful what you wish for
be careful what you wish for interesting
you know
um you think you know the way the world
works
little girl
you have no idea you know so it's kind
of dark it was kind of a dark theme sure
yeah